imaginen que tienen una fuente de sonido
esto podría ser un oscilador que está
generando una onda en una cuerda o un
remo que se mueve arriba abajo y que
crea ondas en el agua o incluso una
bocina que crea ondas de sonido esta
puede ser cualquier fuente de onda que
crea esta onda armónica simple ahora
digamos que tenemos otra fuente de onda
si tomamos esta segunda fuente de onda y
la ponemos básicamente encima de la
primera fuente de onda vamos a tener
interferencia de onda ya que la
interferencia de onda ocurre cuando dos
ondas se superponen y si queremos saber
cómo va a lucir la onda total vamos a
sumar las contribuciones de cada una de
las zonas individuales aquí ponemos un
fondo para ayudarlos a medir las
unidades y así poder sumar las
contribuciones de cada onda el punto de
equilibrio se encuentra justo aquí que
es en donde la onda tendría un valor de
0 y la onda total la vamos a encontrar
sumando las contribuciones de las ondas
individuales
así que si sumamos las contribuciones de
la onda
y la onda 2 aquí la onda 1 tiene un
valor de 1 y la onda 2 también tiene un
valor de 1 una unidad más una unidad nos
da dos unidades por lo que la onda total
va a tener un valor de 2 aquí y 0
unidades +0 unidad después nos va a dar
0 unidades menos 1 y menos 1 nos da
menos 2 y seguimos haciendo esto y nos
damos cuenta de que vamos a tener una
onda coseno bastante grande y decimos
que estas ondas se están interfiriendo
constructivamente a esto le llamamos
interferencia constructiva porque ambas
ondas se combinan para crear una onda
que es el doble de alta que las
originales cuando dos ondas se combinan
para formar una onda más grande debemos
interferencia constructiva y ya que
estas ondas se están combinando
perfectamente ustedes podrán referirse a
esto como una interferencia
perfectamente constructiva o
interferencia totalmente constructiva
pueden imaginarse casos en donde las
ondas no se alinean perfectamente pero
aún así se obtiene una onda total más
grande interferencia constructiva aunque
no va a ser una interferencia
perfectamente constructiva así que esto
es la interferencia constructiva porque
estas ondas fueron constructivas bueno
ven esta onda 2 luce exactamente igual a
como luce la onda 1 simplemente las
trasladamos y obtuvimos una onda que
vale el doble de las originales y quizás
me puedan decir bajar esto no es muy
impresionante pero vean esto digamos que
tenemos otra fuente de onda 2 es
diferente tiene un desfasamiento en pie
porque vean en lugar de comenzar en un
máximo esta nueva onda comienza en un
mínimo así que está adelantada medio
ciclo
o quizá está atrasada medio ciclo con
respecto a la honda 1 medio ciclo espín
ya que todo el ciclo es 2 pi y a menudo
las personas se refieren a esto como
desfase de pi o desfase de 180 grados de
cualquier forma se encuentra fuera de
fase comparada con la fuente de onda 1
por medio ciclo y qué pasa si sobre
ponemos estas dos quitamos esto y tras
la para mos estas dos para ver qué
ocurre y ahora haremos el mismo análisis
aquí no necesito las líneas de fondo ya
que vean que tengo 1 y menos 1 1 y menos
1 es 0 0 y 0 también es 0 1 y menos 100
y 0 es cero no importa en donde me
encuentre un medio y menos un medio es
cero
estas dos ondas cuando se traslapan me
van a dar cero y a esto le llamamos
interferencia destructiva ya que estas
dos ondas esencialmente se destruyen
mutuamente lo que parece una locura
dos ondas se sumen y den nada hay alguna
aplicación para esto claro que sí
imaginen que se encuentran en un
aeroplano y están escuchando el molesto
retumbar de los motores lo cual es
bastante molesto en nuestro oído lo que
hacen es ponerse sus audífonos de
cancelación de ruido y qué hacen estos
audífonos de cancelación de ruido pues
cuando los tenemos puestos van a
escuchar la onda de sonido que se acerca
a nuestro oído y cancelan este sonido
generando su propio sonido pero los
audífonos van a desfasar en esta señal
de manera que coincide con ese retumbar
de la frecuencia de los motores y
producen su sonido igual pero que está
desfasado en pie de manera que ambas
señales se cancelan y su oído no escucha
nada aunque bueno muchas veces no es
completamente silencioso no son
perfectos pero trabajan
sorprendentemente bien esencialmente
combaten fuego con fuego ya que combaten
sonido con más sonido y se basan en esta
idea de interferencia destructiva
no son perfectamente destructivos
pero las ondas que dibujamos aquí si son
perfectamente destructivas se cancelan
perfectamente y a esto le llamamos
interferencia perfectamente destructiva
o interferencia totalmente destructiva y
esto sucede porque estamos mandando una
señal que está desfasada en pi con
respecto a la primera quiero mostrarles
algo interesante y vamos a quitar esto
por el momento nos quedamos con la
fuente de onda 1 y regresamos con la
fuente de onda 2 que teníamos
anteriormente esta es la onda que es
idéntica a esta otra onda si las
trasladamos o superponemos vamos a tener
una interferencia perfectamente
constructiva ya que los picos se alinean
perfectamente con los otros picos lo
mismo sucede con los puntos mínimos o
los valles se alinean perfectamente
entre las dos ondas pero conforme nuevo
hacia adelante la fuente de onda 2 vean
lo que sucede comienzan a desfasarse
cuando están perfectamente alineadas
decimos que están en fase
pero si nuevo una comienzan a
disfrazarse y si desplazo una lo
suficiente vean que comenzamos con una
interferencia constructiva y al mover
una fuente esta situación se vuelve
destructiva
ahora los picos se están alineando con
los valles y se van a cancelar
mutuamente si muevo hacia adelante mi
fuente 2 un poco más se van a alinear de
nuevo perfectamente y tendremos
interferencia constructiva pero si la
muevo más tendré interferencia
destructiva y si lo sigo haciendo pasaré
de interferencia constructiva a
destructiva
una y otra vez así que en otras palabras
una forma de obtener interferencia
destructiva es tomar dos fuentes de onda
que comiencen igual es decir que estén
en fase las ponemos juntas y así tenemos
interferencia constructiva para obtener
interferencia destructiva si tenemos una
señal desfasada y veces y las ponemos
juntas vamos a tener la interferencia
destructiva ya que todos los picos
coinciden con los valles pero
la forma de obtener interferencia
constructiva o destructiva es comenzar
con dos ondas que se encuentren en fase
y asegurarnos de que una de ellas se
mueva hacia adelante comparada con la
otra pero qué tan lejos deberemos de
moverla para obtener interferencia
constructiva o destructiva vamos a
probarlo comenzamos aquí y cuando están
juntas tenemos interferencia
constructiva y si muevo mi fuente de
onda 2 que estaba originalmente en fase
con la primera y la pongo aquí tendré
interferencia constructiva qué tan lejos
la moví la móvil hasta acá la parte de
enfrente de la bocina llego aquí qué tan
lejos fue vamos a quitar esto y vemos
que fue una longitud de onda ya que va
de pico a pico una longitud de onda
exacta suponiendo que estas dos ondas
tienen la misma longitud de onda cada
una
no tengo que lo que hicimos en esencia
fue que la onda de la fuente de onda 2
no tuvo que viajar tan lejos para ello
hasta donde sea que estemos detectando
el sonido podemos tener un oído acá o
algún detector científico que registre
el sonido la onda de la fuente 2 está
viajando solamente esta distancia para
llegar al detector mientras que la onda
de la fuente 1 está viajando toda esta
distancia en otras palabras la onda 1
está viajando una longitud de onda más
que la onda de la fuente 2 y así ambas
quedan en fase y tendremos interferencia
constructiva pero esta no es la única
opción que podemos tener si seguimos
moviendo la fuente de onda 2 hacia
adelante y la ponemos hasta acá otra
longitud de onda hacia adelante
obtendremos nuevamente interferencia
constructiva y en este momento la onda
de la fuente uno tiene que viajar dos
longitudes de onda más que la onda de la
fuente 2 y quizá ustedes ya hayan
detectado este patrón no importa cuántas
longitudes de onda se mueva la fuente
hacia adelante siempre y cuando sea una
cantidad entera de longitudes de onda
cada vez interferencia constructiva así
que algo que resulta ser útil es la
fórmula que resulta de decirnos cuál
deberá ser la diferencia en la longitud
de la ruta vamos a llamar a esta x2
porque viene de la fuente 2 es la
distancia que tiene que viajar la onda
de la fuente 2 para llegar al receptor y
la distancia x1 va a ser la distancia
que tiene que recorrer la onda de la
fuente 1 para llegar a este mismo
receptor y podemos escribir una forma
que relacione la diferencia entre ambas
distancias de la longitud de la ruta que
llamaremos delta x que es la distancia
que tiene que viajar
la onda 1 x 1 menos la distancia viajada
por la onda 2 y con base en lo que vimos
aquí si esta diferencia en las
distancias siempre es igual a un número
entero de longitudes de onda
por ejemplo 0 que es el caso en el que
ambas se encuentran juntas tenemos
interferencia constructiva cuando
tenemos esto igual a lambda
una longitud de onda también tendremos
constructiva si esto es igual a dos
longitudes de onda también tendremos
interferencia constructiva y en este
caso cualquier cantidad entera de
longitudes de onda no usa la
interferencia constructiva y como
obtendremos la interferencia destructiva
pues vamos a continuar con esta fuente
de onda que comenzó originalmente en
fase así que estas dos fuentes de onda
comienzan en fase qué tan lejos tengo
que mover esta fuente para tener
interferencia destructiva pues veamos
tengo que moverla hasta que llegue aquí
qué tan lejos movimos la parte de
enfrente de esta bocina pues fue esta
distancia que si quito esto me daré
cuenta de que es media longitud de onda
de pico a valle media longitud de onda y
esta no es la única opción
sigo moviendo mi fuente 2 hacia adelante
y aquí es constructiva seguimos hasta
llegar de nuevo a destructiva que
viajamos en esta distancia más
qué tan lejos fue quitamos esto y vemos
que esto es una longitud de onda noten
que en este punto la onda de la fuente
uno tiene que viajar una y media
longitudes de onda más para llegar al
receptor al menos comparada con la
fuente 2 seguimos moviendo nuestra
fuente 2 un poco más esto es
constructivo seguimos y de nuevo es
destructiva y viajamos esta distancia
más que es igual a otra longitud de onda
más si quitamos esto vemos que aquí
coincide valle con valle y es otra
longitud de onda completa y en este caso
la onda 1 tuvo que viajar dos y media
longitudes de onda más que la onda 2 así
que cada vez que la onda uno tiene que
viajar media longitud de onda más que la
onda dos tendremos interferencia
destructiva es decir si esta diferencia
en la longitud de la ruta es igual a
lambda entre 23 lambda entre 2 que es
una y media lambda
cinco lámparas entre dos que son dos y
media longitudes de onda y así
sucesivamente obtendremos interferencia
destructiva esta es la diferencia de la
longitud de la ruta entre dos fuentes de
onda que puedan determinar si voy a
obtener una interferencia constructiva o
una interferencia destructiva pero vean
que comenzamos con dos fuentes de onda
que iniciaban en fase por lo que todo
este análisis de aquí supone que ambas
fuentes comenzaron en fase entre sí es
decir ninguna de ellas tenían un
desfasamiento de pi que nos dará este
análisis si tenemos fuentes que
comienzan con un desfase de pi quitamos
esta onda 2 y ponemos esta otra onda
desfasada esta onda 2 está desfasada en
pi con respecto a la onda 1 así que la
ponemos aquí quitamos esto y ahora
cuando están juntas estas dos fuentes de
onda
tendremos interferencia destructiva en
este caso para una diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta igual a cero
ambas están viajando la misma distancia
para llegar al receptor así que x1 y x2
van a ser iguales por lo que al restar
las vamos a tener cero en esta ocasión
el cero no se está dando destructiva en
lugar de constructiva veamos qué pasa si
muevo mi fuente 2 hacia adelante veamos
que tanto tenemos que desplazarla para
obtener nuevamente interferencia
destructiva la tenemos que mover hasta
acá qué tan lejos la movemos pues
movimos la fuente de esta bocina esta
distancia que es toda una longitud de
onda si quitamos esto vemos que nos
movimos de pico a pico y aquí nuevamente
tenemos interferencia destructiva así
que de nuevo aquí cero nos dio
interferencia destructiva lambda o una
longitud de onda nos da también
interferencia destructiva y se darán
cuenta de que todas las distancias que
tienen longitudes de onda enteras nos
van a dar interferencia destructiva esto
lo muevo hacia adelante otra longitud de
onda y de nuevo obtengo interferencia
destructiva
ya que todos los picos se alinean con
los valles
así que lo interesante es que si dos
fuentes inician estando desfasadas mil
veces vamos a tener esto lo cambiamos
cuando comienzan con un desfase de pi
entonces las diferencias en la longitud
de la ruta que sean igual a 0 lambda 2
lambda etcétera no nos darán
interferencia constructiva sino que nos
darán interferencia destructiva y quizá
ya se imaginen que nos darán estas
diferencias en la longitud de la ruta
que sean iguales a mitades de longitudes
de onda vamos a averiguarlo comenzamos
con las dos fuentes juntas quitamos esto
y ahora movemos esto hacia adelante
media longitud de onda
en efecto interferencia constructiva así
que si muevo esta fuente que ya tiene un
desplazamiento en pie media longitud de
onda hacia adelante en lugar de tener
una interferencia destructiva voy a
tener una interferencia constructiva y
si la muevo otra longitud
onda hacia adelante hasta acá noten que
esta onda de la fuente uno tiene que
recorrer una y media longitudes de onda
más con respecto a la onda de la fuente
dos que son tres medios de longitudes de
onda por lo que algo que comenzó siendo
destructivo
ahora se alinean perfectamente para
darnos algo constructivo y se darán
cuenta que todas estas diferencias en la
longitud de la ruta que son mitades de
longitudes de onda en lugar de darnos
interferencia destructiva nos darán
interferencia constructiva ya que una de
estas fuentes de onda tiene un
desplazamiento de pi en comparación con
la otra así que podemos decir que cuando
dos fuentes comienzan con un desfase de
pi en lugar de llevarnos a interferencia
destructiva esto nos dará interferencia
constructiva y estas ideas son la base
de todos los patrones de interferencia
que van a encontrar en el universo lo
que es genial si ustedes se encuentran
con algún patrón de interferencia
se deba a esto y si hay una ecuación que
ustedes tengan que usar muy
probablemente esté fundamentada en esta
idea si es que tiene interferencia de
onda en ella y aquí quiero agregar algo
más
las fuentes no necesariamente tienen que
comenzar desfasadas a veces en donde
estén viajando pueden ocurrir las cosas
es un universo muy loco y quizá una de
las ondas fue desfasada en el transcurso
del viaje pero sin importar por qué si
una de ellas termina con un
desfasamiento de pi ya sea desde el
inicio o después vamos a usar esta
segunda condición de aquí para saber si
vamos a obtener una interferencia
destructiva o una interferencia
constructiva y si ninguna de ellas tiene
un cambio de fase o si ambas tuvieron el
mismo cambio de fase vamos a usar esta
condición de aquí pueden imaginarse que
se intercambia a la fase en ambas pero
si ambas lo hacen pues no quedarán
desfasadas entre sí en resumen la
interferencia constructiva ocurre
cuando dos ondas se alinean
perfectamente la interferencia
destructiva ocurre cuando los picos
coinciden con los valles y se cancelan
por completo y pueden usar la diferencia
en la longitud de la ruta para dos
fuentes de onda y así determinar si
estas ondas tendrán una interferencia
constructiva o una interferencia
destructiva entre sí la diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta es la diferencia de
lo que una onda tiene que viajar para
llegar al detector comparada con la
longitud que la segunda onda tiene que
viajar para llegar al mismo receptor y
suponiendo que ambas fuentes comienzan
en fase es decir que ninguna fue
desfasada en el camino las diferencias
en la longitud de la ruta que sean
longitudes de ondas enteras nos darán
interferencia constructiva
proporcionales a mitades de longitudes
de onda nos darán interferencia
destructiva y si nuestras dos fuentes
inician con un desfase de pi o alguna de
ellas se desfasó pib
en el camino las longitudes de onda
enteras en las diferencias de la
longitud de la ruta nos darán
interferencia destructiva y las mitades
de longitudes de onda en la diferencia
de la longitud de la ruta nos darán
interferencia constructiva